I want to talk today about how reading
can change our lives and about the
limits of that change I want to talk to
you about how reading can give us a
shareable world of powerful human
connection but also about how that
connection is always partial how reading
is ultimately a lonely idiosyncratic
undertaking the writer who changed my
life was a the great African American
novelist James Baldwin when I was
growing up in Western Michigan in the
1980s there weren't many Asian American
writers interested in social change and
so I think I turned to James Baldwin as
a way to fill this void as a way to feel
racially conscious but perhaps because I
knew I wasn't myself African American I
also felt challenged and indicted by his
words especially these words there are
liberals who have all the proper
attitudes but no real convictions when
the chips are down and you somehow
expect them to deliver they're somehow
not there they're somehow not there
I took those words very literally where
should I put myself I went to the
Mississippi Delta one of the poorest
regions the United States
this is a place shaped by a powerful
history in the 1960s african-americans
risked their lives to fight for
education to fight for the right to vote
I wanted to be a part of that change to
help young teenagers graduate and go to
college when I got to the Mississippi
Delta it was a place that was still poor
still segregated still dramatically a
need of change my school where I was
placed
had no library no guidance counselor but
it did have a police officer half the
teachers were substitutes and when
students got into fights the school
would send them to the local County Jail
this is a school where I met Patrick he
was fifteen and held back twice he was
in the eighth grade he was quiet
introspective like he was always in deep
thought and he hated seeing other people
fight I saw him once jump between two
girls when they got into a fight and he
got himself knocked to the ground
Patrick had just one problem he wouldn't
come to school he said that sometimes
school was just too depressing because
people were always fighting and teachers
were quitting and also his mother worked
two jobs and was just too tired to make
him come so I made it my job to get him
to come to school and because I was
crazy and 22 and zealously optimistic my
strategy was just to show up at his
house and say hey why don't you come to
school and the strategy actually worked
he started to come to school every day
and he started to flourish in my class
he was writing poetry he was reading
books he was coming to school every day
around the same time that I had figured
out how to connect to Patrick I got into
law school at Harvard I once again faced
this question where should I put myself
where do I put my body and I thought to
myself that the Mississippi Delta was a
place where people with money people
with opportunity those people leave and
the people who stay behind are the
people who don't have the chance to
leave I didn't want to be a person who
left and wanted to be a person who
stayed on the other hand I was lonely
and tired and so I convinced myself that
I could do more change on a larger scale
if I had a prestigious law degree still
I left three years later when I was
about to graduate from law school my
friend called me and told me that
Patrick had got into a fight and killed
someone I was devastated part of me
didn't believe it but part of me also
knew that it was true I flew down to see
Patrick I visited him in jail and he
told me that it was true that he had
killed someone and he didn't want to
talk more about it I asked him what had
happened with school and he said he had
dropped out the year after I left and
then he wanted to tell me something else
he looked down he said that he had had a
baby daughter who was just born and he
felt like he had let her down
that was it our conversation was rushed
and awkward when I stepped outside the
jail a voice inside me said come back if
you don't come back now you'll never
come back so I graduated from law school
and I went back and went back to see
Patrick and went back to see if I could
help him with his legal case and this
time when I saw him a second time I had
I thought I had this great idea I said
hey Patrick why don't you write a letter
to your daughter
so that you can keep her on your mind
and I had it of a pen and a piece of
paper and he started to write but what I
saw at the paper that he handed back to
me I was shocked I didn't recognize his
handwriting he had made simple spelling
mistakes and I thought to myself that as
a teacher I knew that a student could
dramatically improve in a very quick
amount of time
but I never
thought that a student could
dramatically regress what even pained me
more was seeing what he had written to
his daughter he had ruin I'm sorry for
my mistakes I'm sorry for not being
there for you and this was all he felt
he had to say to her and I asked myself
how can I convince him that he has more
to say parts of himself that he doesn't
need to apologize for I wanted him to
feel that he had something worthwhile to
share with his daughter for every day
the next 7 months I visited and brought
books my tote bag became a little
library
I brought James Baldwin I brought Walt
Whitman CS Lewis I brought guide books
to trees to birds and what would become
his favorite book the dictionary on some
days we would sit in hours for silence
both of us reading and on other days we
would read together we would read poetry
we started by reading haikus hundreds of
haikus a deceptively simple masterpiece
and I would ask him share with me your
favorite haikus and here there some of
them are quite funny so there's this
bias ax don't worry spiders I keep house
casually and this mapped half the day no
one punished me and this gorgeous one
which is about the first day of snow
falling deer licking first frost from
each other's coats there's something
mysterious and gorgeous just about the
way up home looks the empty space is as
important as the words themselves we
read this poem by LWS merwin which he
wrote after he saw his wife and working
in the garden and realized that they
would spend the rest of their lives
together
let me imagine that we will come again
when we want to and it will be spring we
will be no older than we ever were the
warring griefs will have eased like the
early cloud through which morning slowly
comes to itself
I asked Patrick what his favorite line
was and he said we will be no older than
we ever were he said I reminded him of a
place where time just stops where time
doesn't matter anymore
and I asked him if he had a place like
that where time lasts forever
and he said my mother when you read up
home alongside someone else the poem
changes and meaning because it becomes
personal to that person it becomes
personal to you we then read books we
read so many books we ride the member of
Frederick Douglass an American slave who
taught himself to read and write and who
escaped her freedom because of his
literacy I had grown up thinking of
Frederick Douglass as a hero and I
thought of the story is one of uplift
and hope but this book put Patrick in a
kind of panic he fixated on a story
Douglass told of how over Christmas
masters give slaves gin as a way to
prove to them that they can't handle
freedom because slaves would be
stumbling on the fields patrick said he
related to this he said that there are
people in jail who like slaves don't
want to think about their condition
because it's too painful too painful to
think about the past too painful to
think about how how far we have to go
his favorite line was this line anything
no matter what to get rid of thinking it
was this everlasting thinking of my
condition
that tormented me patrick said that
Douglass was brave too right to keep
thinking but Patrick would
never know how much he seemed like
Douglas to me how he kept reading even
though it put him in a panic he finished
the book before I did reading it in a
concrete stairway with no light and then
we went on to read one of my favorite
books Marilyn Robinson's Gilead which is
an extended letter from a father to his
son he loved this line I'm writing this
in part to tell you that if you ever
wonder what you've done in your life you
have been God's grace to me a miracle
something more than a miracle something
about this language it's love it's
longing it's voice rekindled Patrick's
desire to write and he would fill
notebooks upon notebooks of letters with
letters to his daughter and these
beautiful intricate letters he would
imagine he had him and his daughter
going canoeing down the Mississippi
River he would imagine them finding a
mountain stream with perfectly clear
water as I watched Patrick write I
thought to myself and I now ask all of
you how many of you have written a
letter to somebody you feel you have let
down it is just much easier to put those
people out of your mind
but Patrick showed up every day facing
his daughter holding himself accountable
to her word by word with intense
concentration I wanted in my own life to
put myself at risk in that way because
that risk reveals the strength of one's
heart let me take a step back and just
ask an uncomfortable question Who am I
to tell this story is in this Patrick
story
Patrick's the one who lived with this
pain
I have never been hungry a day in my
life I thought about this question a lot
but I what I want to say is that the
story is not just about Patrick it's
about us it's about the inequality
between us the world of Plenty that
Patrick and his parents and his
grandparents have been shut out of in
this story I represent that world of
Plenty
and in telling this story I didn't want
to hide myself hide the power that I do
have and telling the story I wanted to
expose that power and then to ask how do
we diminish the distance between us
reading is one way to close that
distance it gives us a quiet universe
that we can share together that we can
share in equally you're probably
wondering now what happened to Patrick
did reading save his life
it did and it didn't when Patrick got
out of prison his journey was
excruciating
employers turned him away because of his
record his best friend his mother died
at age 43 from heart disease and
diabetes
she's been homeless she's been hungry so
people say a lot of things about reading
that feel exaggerated to me being
literate didn't stop him from being
discriminated against it didn't has
stopped his mother from dying so what
can reading do I have a few answers to
end with today reading charge his inner
life with mystery with imagination with
beauty reading gave him images they gave
him joy Mountain Ocean deer frost words
that taste of a free
natural world reading gave him a
language for what he had lost how
precious are these lines from the poet
derek walcott patrick memorized this
poem days that I have held days that I
have lost days the outgrow like
daughters my harboring arms reading
taught him his own courage remember that
he kept reading Frederick Douglass even
though it was painful he kept being
conscious even though being conscious
hurts
reading is a form of thinking that's why
it's difficult to read because we have
to think and Patrick chose to think
rather than to not think and last
reading gave him a language to speak to
his daughter reading inspired him to
want to write the link between reading
and writing is so powerful when we begin
to read we begin to find the words and
he found the words to imagine the two of
them together
he found the words to tell her how much
he loved her reading also changed our
relationship with each other it gave us
an occasion for intimacy to see beyond
our points of view and reading took an
unequal relationship and gave us a
momentary equality when you meet
somebody as a reader you meet him for
the first time newly freshly there is no
way you can know what his favorite line
will be what memories and private griefs
he has and you face the ultimate privacy
of his inner life and then you start to
wonder well what is my inner life made
of what do I have that's worthwhile to
share with another I want to close
on some of my favorite lines from
Patrick's letters to his daughter
the river is shadowy in some places but
the light shines through the cracks of
trees on some branches hang plenty of
mulberries you stretch your arm straight
out to grab some and this lovely letter
where he writes close your eyes and
listen to the sounds of the words I know
this poem by heart and I would like you
to know it too thank you so much
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]